Hey guys,
and a warm welcome to Orthos Labs,
and more specifically Market Structure OS.
Uhm,
yeah, I mean, pretty simple, take a look around, there's a community aspect to
this where you guys can interact with each other.
Uhm, there isn't really any
activity on my behalf, nor the other mentors' behalves,
as our primary focus, as you guys know,
is over with the school and the live trading floor.
Bye. But this is a community for you guys,
so, yeah, just keep that in mind.
Uhm, heading over to the classroom again,
by the way, you can just create posts by simply clicking write something and,
yeah, title, write something, add videos,
whatever you want. Simple ones.
Obviously to note that no scams,
no self-promotion, no external,
uhm, promotion or external directing people to other
things. Uhm,
over into the classroom. Uh, the start here aspect is,
uhm, is where you're watching this video right now. Uhm,
how you will get access to Markzware 2.0 OS by filling out this form
and one of our, you know,
members of the team will sort your indicator access.
There's currently no way to automate this, so it is manual,
but we do have a team working on it. Around the clock,
24-7, to admit new people into the
indicator. And then there's a very short installation guide in
here. Uhm,
inside of Markzware 2.0 OS training, there's just some simple instructions.
Basic Markzware 2.0 training, and then this is the master key.
What you'll notice with the master key is on your hand, it's probably locked
unless you've paid the $97 one-time fee.
Uhm, inside the master key is the intro
and idea of what I'm actually doing with this.
Like, what is the purpose of this? Um,
and it's really simple. I want to give, uh,
three key examples of one of my A plus setups.
Again, the indicator without a system proven strategy to go with it is
not useless. But not as powerful,
this indicator is what makes market structure easier,
but market structure alone is just simply a tool.
You need how to get in, how to get out, how to manage risk,
where the market is going to reverse from, and so on and so forth.
Direction is a very important part. But it is the first key,
and there are more to it. I also want to explain to you the
daily bias, and I want to show you the
weekly bias. These both being very,
very powerful. and you know,
competent concepts. These,
this daily bias and weekly bias has over 15 years of data behind
it with a 68% accuracy.
So you can predict what the next week's weekly candle or the next day's
daily candle is going to do with a 68% accuracy,
just following the rules that I give you. And then these are really interesting.
Structure and Validation, uh,
part one and part two. Uh,
on average, there's like 30 minutes of content.
And this is me explaining in what scenarios you should actually
ignore market structure. And that sounds counterintuitive,
but the reality is, is there are some times where it's clear that price
is going to continue to train lower, even though market structure tells us that
we're bullish. And it's not. It's really important to know when
those times are, because by knowing when to ignore structure can save
you just as much money that you will make when you're correct.
Really important not to get stuck on the wrong side of the market,
blindly following it. When there are two very important and key rules that can
enable you to not miss out on the move that's going to happen just
because of the market structure indicator, or to actually
get involved in winning moves that go against the structure
indicator will tell you. That's a,
you know, really, really important part. And then finally,
uh, I just kind of walk through my entry model,
uhm, and how I go about framing the
bias in my into an entry and how I actually get
into a position and all of that masterclass
inside of the master key, which again is literally just a one-time payment of
$97 for now. Um,
so yeah, you know, enjoy it if you think it's valuable and don't worry
about it if you think it's not. Enjoy guys.